I think the clip of us is on Twitter's
at over 8 million views now of you
saying uh I told you Mighty Mouse would
beat you up yeah now A little update on
that I spoke to Mighty Mouse yesterday
yes spoke to Mighty Mouse because he
repost the clip and I I tell everybody
all fighters hit me up about you I'm
like Bradley's my boy good dude yeah so
I told uh Mighty Mouse tell you good
dude dude and he's like yeah no doubt
he's like just tell him I'm down he's
like it's not going to go well I'm like
no I know that's what I wanted to go
down and he goes I have to go on
vacation I think he's going I'm gonna
say where he's going but he said I'm
going vacation so let's let's figure it
out but I'll come to La I can't just let
me know I can't wait are you at your
Studios I'm like I'll figure out some
mats yeah